très repousser vos limites voici trois
lieux extrême à découvrir sur terre
pendant une minute 1 est la vallée de la
mort c'est l'endroit le plus chaud de la
terre les températures y dépasse
régulièrement les 50 degrés elle est
située à moins de 200 kilomètres de las
vegas aux états unis dans le désert des
mojaves deux le désert d'atacama au
chili c'est l'endroit le plus sec comme
on l'imaginé certaines zones n'ont
jamais reçu la moindre goutte de pluie
il faut en moyenne
0,1 mm de pluie parrot ses 250 x mois
que dans le sahara conséquence on y
trouve presque aucune forme de vie
organique 3 l'everest c'est le sommet le
plus haut de notre planète 8848 m il est
situé à la frontière du népal et de la
chine dans la chaîne de l'himalaya la
première expédition de 1922 et depuis de
plus en plus d'alpinistes tant que
l'ascension est de plus en plus cela
réussisse leur nombre a doublé au cours
des trente dernières années 2010neuf
l'everest a connu son record de
fréquentation avec 885 alpinistes qui
ont atteint 100 sont menées